hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be breaking
down step by step how you can find your
perfect rental property specifically for
air b and b so if you've wanted to get
into serviced accommodation if you've
thought about buying an apartment and
trying it on airbnb or maybe you're
thinking about doing a rent to service
department but you're thinking how do i
know the right area i don't know if this
property is going to work then this
video is for you i've never revealed
this before on youtube but i'm about to
break it down in four simple steps by
the way if you enjoy my channel do me a
favor and hit the like button because it
really helps the youtube algorithm so
the first step okay this is an acronym
right now and it's f l a t flat an
apartment is basically a flat so how are
you going to find your perfect flat f l
a t number one
it's really easy to see somebody far
away making crazy money let's say in
bournemouth or manchester and think
you've got to go to that area but f
is for finding an area that you are
familiar with you want to be investing
close to home where you know the area so
if you're based in birmingham start
looking at birmingham to begin with if
you're based in manchester look at
manchester if you're in edinburgh look
at edinburgh don't think that there's a
golden
magic city because there's not
ultimately if you're in a um an area
where there's lots of people and there's
jobs and there's things going on then
that's okay so start with areas that
you're familiar with that aren't too far
from home another really important
reason for this is when you get a
service department to begin with it's
gonna be a bit of work you're gonna be
having to go back and forth you're gonna
have to be furnishing it and if it's a
three hour drive a six hour round trip
it's gonna make things really
challenging so firstly look for areas
look for cities and towns that are close
to home that you are familiar with
that's the first step step number two is
l which is for
legals so legals there are there is some
legislation in doing serviced
accommodation uh for example if you are
doing this in central london you if
you're in greater london there is a
90-day rule that says that you have to
get planning permission if you're
wanting to rent out your apartment or
your house on short stay let's for more
than 90 days a year now in england
london is currently the only area that
has this rule but there are other legal
requirements that you need to look at
for example if you're buying a property
with the intention of renting it out on
short stay let's you need to make sure
that your mortgage lender
allows you to do that if you're doing a
rent to rent you need to make sure that
your landlord
gives you permission to rent it out on
airbnb so there are legal requirements
that you need to be mindful of before
you go ahead and just do it so choose an
area you're familiar with start looking
at apartments but look at the legalities
also if you're doing a part if you're in
an apartment block there might be a head
lease restriction that prevents you from
renting out a property within the block
on short stay let's so look at the
legals and make sure that you have the
green light to go ahead
next a
a is for access what do i mean by access
so your guests when they're coming from
airbnb to check in the property they're
gonna need access to the property and
they're gonna need access without you
being there if you're having to go and
let guests in every time this is just
going to be an absolute nightmare so you
need to put a key safe outside the
property now there are some properties
or apartment blocks where this isn't
convenient maybe there's like a gate and
it's just a bit awkward or maybe the
freeholder doesn't allow key saves on
the block so you need to be thinking
before you take on an apartment whether
it be for rent to rent or to buy you'd
be thinking well how are my guests going
to get in how are they going to access
the property so a access and then
finally t
is for drumroll
tourism
so if you're buying an apartment in an
area you need to be making sure that
this area there are attractions there
are tourists now don't get me wrong
tourists aren't the only type of guests
there are also
business professionals there are
contractors there are relocators but
generally speaking you're going to get
much more bookings if there's tourists
and this thing around how do you know if
there's tourists in an area let's say
your area is manchester typing google
things to do in manchester if there's
like 02 arenas and there's museums and
there's theaters and there's lots of
things around to do
that's a good sign that there's going to
be tourists in that area if you type in
things to do in and you type an area and
the top thing is there's a park bench
that you can sit on that's probably a
bad sign so you want to make sure that
there are tourists there are people
around also before you take on an
apartment do you do diligence so you can
do this by looking at other people's
airbnb um adverts look at their calendar
and see how booked up it is
see how much they're charging and how
booked up it is look at hotels in the
area go on booking.com and search for
rooms in
such and such an area and if it's all
fully booked up that's a really good
sign that your your property is going to
be booked up as well so tourists due
diligence market research really really
really important if you follow these
four points if you're in an area that
you're familiar with if you check the
legals and all the legal requirements
and permissions if you make sure there's
good access and if there's tourists in
the area then you have congratulations
found your perfect
rental airbnb apartment thanks for
watching i'll see you next time
[Music]
you